pose qu'on puisse commencer rapidement
la technique est en place tout le monde
a rejoint ses places mes chers collègues
notre du jour appelle à présent
l'audition commune sur l'enquête
réalisée par la Cour des comptes à la
demande de notre commission en
application de l'article
132-3-1 du Code des juridictions
financières sur santé publique France
nous accueillons ce matin Madame
Véronique à maillon présidente messieurs
Jérôme Daussy et Sébastien Gallet
conseiller référendaire de la sixième
chambre de la Cour des comptes pour la
présentation de l'enquête nous avons
également convié comme cela a pu être le
cas par le passé pour d'autres contrôles
organiques les principales parties
prenantes madame Marianne Jacquet
directrice générale par intérim de santé
publique France Madame Catherine grenier
directrice des assurés de la Caisse
nationale d'assurance
financeur de l'agence le représentant de
la Direction générale de la santé du
ministère de la santé et de la
prévention tutelle de l'agence est
exclusé pour cause de tripes épidémiques
j'indique que cette audition fait
l'objet d'une captation vidéo
retransmise en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat puis disponible en
vidéo à la demande notre Commission a
demandé à la Cour des comptes la
réalisation de cette enquête il y a un
an en décembre 2021 notre présidente
maudit baisse la demande par les
difficultés observées dans le
positionnement de l'agence dans ses
relations avec l'administration centrale
du ministère de la Santé pour ceux qui
concerne notamment les missions de l'exé
Prusse pour lesquels elles ne disent
posent pas d'une réelle autonomie
je crois que nous avons tous en tête
pour ceux qui étaient à leur présents
une audition de mai 2020 au cours de
laquelle nous avons assisté à de
multiples renvois de responsabilités
entre l'agence et sa tutelle sur la
question des équipements de protection
la demande de notre président portait
sur un bilan de fonctionnement de la
nouvelle agence au triple plan de sa
gouvernance de son organisation et de sa
gestion une analyse des moyens de
l'agence aux missions qui lui sont
assignées un questionnement sur la place
de l'agence dans le paysage
administratif et institutionnels une
appréciation sur ce que notre commission
considère comme des débuts de
cétisations de fait de dépenses au cours
de la crise sanitaire à la suite du
transfert à l'assurance maladie du
financement de santé publique France
auparavant assuré par les crédits de la
mission santé du budget de l'État
madame la Présidente à maillon je vous
laisse la parole sans plus tarder enfin
que vous puissiez présenter les travaux
de la cour
merci Madame
merci madame la Présidente
alors on vous présente un powerpoint
assez assez rapidement pour rappeler les
points principaux points pardon de ce
rapport qui nous a été demandé vous
l'avez rappelé par le Sénat la
commission des affaires sociales du
Sénat le 14 décembre 2021 sur santé
publique France donc plusieurs questions
nous étaient posées notamment sur le
positionnement de santé publique France
par rapport à l'administration centrale
aux autres agences sanitaires et aux ARS
sur la répartition des missions de SPF
avec les administrations centrales et
avec d'autres agences sur l'adéquation
de ces moyens par rapport à ses missions
sur le mode de financement de ces
missions et sur l'effectivité ou pas des
gains déficience attendus de la création
de santé publique France en 2016 et plus
largement sur le fonctionnement de santé
publique France nous nous avons mené
également des comparaisons
internationales comme nous y invitait le
Sénat nous avons pu le faire dans une
certaine mesure sur un certain nombre de
sujets comme les stocks stratégiques et
comme la prévention et la promotion de
la santé en revanche il ne nous a pas
été possible d'en tirer des conclusions
sur la comparaison des moyens entre SPF
et ses homologues étrangers notamment
britanniques américains ou Canadiens
compte tenu des différences de
portefeuilles de mission c'est le
périmètre d'émissions de chacune de ces
entités et en raison du fait qu'il n'a
pas été possible non plus d'accéder à la
comptabilité analytique de ces
organismes
les différences entre les modèles
étrangers et santé publique France
s'explique notamment par des raisons
historiques l'agence française ne
dispose pas en propre de moyens de
recherche et son effectif qui se
consacre à la prévention et la promotion
de la santé et significativement
inférieur à celui de ses homologues
étrangers
alors nous avons
nous sommes partis évidemment d'un état
des lieux des rapports qui préexistaient
à notre rapport des rapports de la Cour
des comptes que vous avez à l'écran des
rapports du Parlement et notamment un
rapport de la commission d'enquête du
Sénat de 2020 et puis le rapport pitté
bien sûr et un certain nombre d'autres
rapports je passe je passe rapidement
sur les constats relatifs à santé
publique France alors la Cour
constate que santé publique France joue
un rôle essentiel dans l'organisation de
la surveillance et de la veille
sanitaire
SPF réceptionne les signaux issus des
dispositifs d'alerte et de surveillance
les traites pour déclarer s'il y a lieu
une alerte sanitaire à bon escient au
mystère de la santé il est donc à la
fois acteur et organisateur de ces
dispositifs la période contrôlée par la
Cour se caractérise par à la fois une
extension des dispositifs de
surveillance et de veille sanitaire
parfois obsolète et également par une
recherche d'identification des signaux
précoces et de ce qu'on appelle les
signaux faibles
nous avons constaté qu'il existe
aujourd'hui une vaste palette de
dispositifs de veille et de surveillance
qui s'étend au cours du temps de notre
de notre contrôle pour couvrir de la
manière la plus exhaustive possible les
risques potentiels pour la santé
mais
nous avons pointé également un certain
nombre de limites à ces dispositifs
notamment l'ancienneté du système
d'information de surveillance
syndromique et la limite liée à certains
registres qui a des limites qui avaient
été pointées par le Haut Conseil de la
santé publique
là le coq pardon le contrat d'objectif
et de performance 2018-2022 de santé
publique France demandait à l'agence
d'analyser la pertinence des dispositifs
existants cela n'a pas été fait donc
nous pointons ce point-là
il existe un selon nous un réel besoin
d'évaluation pour venir mieux traiter
les signaux ça a donné lieu donc ce
constat à donner lieu à une
recommandation dans notre rapport qui
est de relancer les travaux d'analyse de
la pertinence des dispositifs de
surveillance et de quantifier les
besoins futurs de santé publique France
pour procéder aux déclenchement des
alertes sanitaires
sur les stocks stratégiques
nous avons constaté évidemment le
changement important de dimension sous
l'effet de la crise sanitaire avec une
valeur des stocks avant des prestations
10 fois supérieures en 2021 à ce qu'il
s'était afin 2019 donc on est passé à de
200 millions à plus de 2 milliards sur
essentiellement les équipements de
protection individuelle
la question de la dépréciation des
équipements de protection individuels a
été regardé attentivement par la Cour
elle revait évidemment une ampleur
nouvelle compte tenu des montants en jeu
et la question se pose des dépréciations
qui seront à constater des moyens qui
seront alloués à senti public France et
que santé publique France se donnera
pour
constater ses dépréciations et
renouveler le stock donc il y a un coût
à assumer sur lequel nous attirons
l'attention de santé publique France
sur la mise en oeuvre du cadre d'emploi
des socles stratégiques la Cour des
comptes a considéré que ce cadre
d'emploi appelait des précisions en
fonction notamment de la ce qu'on
appelle la cinétique des événements de
la rapidité de l'ampleur des des
épidémies ou des événements sanitaires
la réponse ne peut pas être la même et
doit être mieux gradué et mieux évalué
enfin
la question importante du maintien de la
mission relative au stock stratégique au
sein de SPF France ou pas fallait-il
maintenir cette mission au sein de SPF
ou pas donc cette question a bien sûr
été posée nous ne proposons pas
de remettre en cause l'organisation
retenue en 2016
l'agence n'est pas responsable selon
nous du niveau des stocks à l'orée de la
crise sanitaire dans la mesure où elle
agit comme un opérateur de l'État
pour cette mission là en particulier
donc tant que l'agence est un opérateur
de l'État l'État reste responsable
infini de la gestion des stocks
stratégiques
nonobstant nous proposons dans notre
rapport
d'élargir les compétences de SPF
à la gestion des enfin
nous proposons que SPF pardon et la
faculté de s'auto saisir de la question
de la gestion des stocks stratégiques
pour émettre des recommandations à
destination du ministère de la Santé
sur la prévention et la promotion de la
santé nous constatons donc un budget en
forte hausse qui est passé de 50 9
millions à 84 millions d'euros entre
2017 et 2021 hors dotation
exceptionnelle
et juste sur la question de la mission
prévention et promotion de la santé
cette forte augmentation est liée
principalement principalement pardon à
la campagne d'information sur les 1000
premiers jours et dans une moindre
mesure aux actions sur les addictions
les effectifs en équivalent temps plein
sont nettement moins élevés
j'ai fait référence tout à l'heure que
ce par exemple de l'Office britannique
on a sur cette mission de prévention et
promotion de la santé 72 équivalentes en
plein chez SPF contre 1000 pour le
Britannique donc voilà on n'est pas du
tout dans les mêmes ordres de grandeur
et c'est la raison pour laquelle il est
extrêmement difficile et délicat délicat
surtout
il faut être prudent quand on fait des
comparaisons internationales
nous constatons un continuum de santé
publique qui est en cours de
consolidation avec des campagnes sur la
nutrition ou le tabac ou l'alcoolisme
qui qui continue en revanche nous avons
constaté que certains champs n'étaient
pas du tout investis ou pas assez par
santé publique France notamment le chant
de la santé mentale
l'établissement de programme de
formation à l'éducation pour la santé
alors on voit que les choses changent un
petit peu comment ça évoluer sous
l'effet de la crise sanitaire mais ces
manques là sont pointés dans le rapport
également un retard
sensible dans l'identification et la
promotion des actions qu'on appelle
prometteuses ou probantes
alors que la demande existait bien
antérieurement avant la crise sanitaire
donc dès 2016 il était demandé en effet
de mettre en œuvre des programmes
objectifs par des données
épidémiologiques probantes et des
indicateurs pertinents ainsi qu'un
référentiel des actions probantes
le constat que nous faisons c'est qu'en
réalité très peu d'actions ont été
conduites sur sur ce thème là
et peu d'action probante ont été
identifiées c'est la raison pour
laquelle la cour recommande dans son
rapport d'enrichir et d'actualiser
régulièrement le référentiel des actions
prometteuses et probantes
enfin sur les services d'aide à distance
en santé téléphonie site internet etc
nous considérons quelles sont
insuffisamment évaluées
en particulier
leur intégration dans les parcours de
santé est insuffisamment évaluée
sur la réserve sanitaire donc nous avons
développé toute une partie du rapport
sur la réserve sanitaire qui a été
mobilisée fortement pendant pendant la
crise
essentiellement d'ailleurs en faveur de
l'Outre-mer comme vous le montre le
graphique en nombre de jours
mobilisés
bon voilà l'augmentation très importante
en 2020 et 2021 et surtout la part
considérable de l'outre-mer dans cette
mobilisation
ce changement de d'échelle entre les
années précovid et les années
covid a été facilité par enfin permis
par l'évolution de la réglementation
puisque le plafond
la période d'emploi maximale de la
réserve est passée de 150 à 180 jours
puis à 300 jours
malgré cela on constate que cet outil a
été un peu dépassé par l'ampleur de la
crise sanitaire covid dès lors que la
pandémie était étendue à tout le
territoire
de surcroît nous constatons que la
gestion administrative de la réserve
sanitaire est défaillante en particulier
là aussi du fait de système
d'information vieillissant et nous
considérons que le cadre stratégique est
à renouveler mais dans une perspective
interministérielle
le cadre d'emploi doit être actualisé
sur plusieurs points il date de 2013 et
il ne correspond plus aujourd'hui aux
besoins qui ont été
identifiés
une demande d'ailleurs avait été
adressée en ce sens à santé publique
France dans le dernier Coop et dans les
priorités annuelles mais elle n'a pas
été satisfaite c'est la raison pour
laquelle la cour fait une recommandation
sur ce point et recommande d'actualiser
le cadre d'emploi de la réserve
sanitaire
selon une vision plus interministérielle
des renforts humains en période de crise
sanitaire
nous avons également regardé la
trajectoire budgétaire
très rapidement donc la situation
financière hors covid globalement
conforté un basculement du dépenses
budgétaires vers un financement
hondables donc depuis la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale de
2020 qui a permis pendant la pandémie
notamment de réviser à plusieurs
reprises les enveloppes exceptionnelles
sans passer par une LFR nous considérons
qu'il faudra néanmoins une information
suffisante du Parlement au moment de la
loi d'approbation des comptes de la
sécurité sociale
donc rendez-vous en 2023
une nous considérons en effet que il y a
aujourd'hui par rapport à la situation
où le financement était essentiellement
budgétaire une perte d'information
financière pour le Parlement que nous
regrettons
notamment la différence enfin nous
pointons la différence entre ce qui
figurait dans le jaune
opérateur et ce qui figure aujourd'hui à
l'annexe 8 du PLFSS et donc nous
recommandons de produire dans l'annexe 8
ou PLFSS les mêmes informations
financières que celles qui figurait dans
le jaune budgétaire auparavant et qui
manque aujourd'hui comme le nombre
d'emplois comme le niveau de trésorerie
comme la surface du parc immobilier
occupé et quelques autres indicateurs
qui ont disparu au passage
avec le financement d'âme et l'annexe 8
au PLFSS
nous vous constatons une progression
continue des concours publics toujours
hors enveloppe exceptionnelle passer de
159 millions pardon 159 millions en 2017
à 248 millions en 2021
les gains de ficience alors nous la
question avait été posée et nous avons
regardé ce point-là
essayant de mesurer l'efficience les
gains déficiences permis par la fusion
des quatre organismes
dont on résulte la création de de SPF
ils sont difficiles à objectiver dans la
durée donc nous n'avons pas de
d'éléments particulièrement saillants et
probants à montrer en la matière sur les
enveloppes exceptionnelles
qui en cumulé
représente 12,8 milliards d'euros
avec un reste à payer de 2,4 milliards
d'euros afin à mai 2022 pardon
[Musique]
essentiellement consacré à l'acquisition
d'équipement de protection individuel et
de
médicaments de réanimation et ensuite de
vaccins quand le vaccin et est apparu
nous critiquons
le recours à plusieurs fonds de concours
financiers pour certaines pour financer
pardon certaines dépenses de l'État
en cumulé sur
2020-2022 c'est ainsi 1,8 milliards
d'euros donc
d'enveloppes exceptionnelle financée sur
fond de concours et nous recommandons à
nouveau de mettre en extension à
l'extinction pardon les fonds de
concours destinés aux FINANCEMENT
D'ACHAT lié à la crise sanitaire et de
les financer par des crédits budgétaires
voilà l'évolution de l'organisation sous
forme d'un schéma qui sera plus parlant
que que de long développement donc
la on voit une réorganisation de
l'Agence
des réorganisations en particulier liées
à la crise covid qui ont montré la
capacité d'adaptation et une certaine
souplesse de d'organisation
nous regrettons toutefois que l'agence a
besoin enfin nous constatons mais d'un
prestataire pour l'élaboration du plan
de continuation d'activité qui est
pourtant un document obligatoire de
longue date de longue date pardon un
document stratégique compte tenu des
missions confiées à l'agence en
particulier et qui aurait dû être
élaboré depuis longtemps
donc ce point là ressort de notre
rapport
de même que le recours à plusieurs
prestataires externes pour la gestion
des stocks et plus généralement la
logistique liée aux équipements de
protection individuelle et au vaccins
sur la gestion des ressources humaines
elle est perfectible on a une maîtrise
de l'effectif malgré tout malgré
quelques dépassements répétés de plafond
d'emploi
comme je l'ai dit tout à l'heure la
comparaison est délicate avec d'autres
opérateurs étrangers elle est délicate
également avec d'autres
[Musique]
oui pardon elle est délicate avec les
autres opérateurs étrangers
mais les chiffres que je vous ai donnés
sont tout de même éloquents
entre les 72 et les milles que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure donc il reste
à
parfaire la gestion des emplois et à
élaborer des parcours professionnels
pour les pour les salariés sur les
systèmes d'information
nous constatons que les progrès ont été
limités depuis la création de l'agence
alors que l'enjeu est évidemment central
pour aspf notamment pour la veille et la
surveillance sanitaire donc il y a là
des enjeux importants de modernisation
et d'interopérabilité des systèmes
d'information
qui était signalée depuis 2016
nous avons constaté aussi une faiblesse
dans la priorisation des chantiers
avec des retards d'exécution dans les
chantiers qui ont conduit donc à
l'obsolescence de nombreuses parties du
système d'information aujourd'hui du SPF
et nous recommandons d'adopter
rapidement un schéma directeur des
systèmes d'information et d'assurer la
déclinaison opérationnelle en priorisant
plus finement les projets associés en
définissant la cible à atteindre et en
élaborant les modalités des modalités de
suivi et nous pointons le risque
d'indisponibilité des systèmes
d'information
qui existe et rien n'est fait
sur la stratégie nous considérons
qu'elle elle reste à clarifier
les attentes en matière de santé
publique sont à clarifiées
sur deux points en particulier nous nous
attirons l'attention sur le fait que le
coq a été adopté tardivement c'est à
dire près deux ans après la création de
l'agence malgré une phase de
préfiguration et que
ce Coop contribue très imparfaitement au
pilotage de l'agence avec des
indicateurs qui sont insuffisamment
précis
il contient 22 objectifs ou de me rendre
non directement rattachable aux
objectifs du programme de 104 et ça te
faiblesse reflète l'absence d'objectifs
nationaux pluriannuel du plan national
priorité prévention
donc on ne constate chez enfin ce qu'on
constate chez SPF n'est que la
déclinaison de ce qu'on constate au
niveau du ministère de la Santé
la démarche de performance donc est à
améliorer on a aujourd'hui une absence
de trajectoire d'amélioration de
l'efficience malgré l'attente de
synergies
depuis la fusion des quatre agents ayant
donné lieu à donner naissance à SPF il
nous avons constaté un foisonnement
programme
peu propice pilotage efficient dans les
différents domaines nous avons plusieurs
programmes
des programmes de travail qui sont
adoptés certes en conseil
d'administration mais qui ne sont pas
corrélés au contrat d'objectifs et de
performance et des programmes de travail
qui ne sont pas priorisés par rapport
aux enjeux sanitaires
donc une réorientation de cette
programmation est en cours depuis 2020
mais l'état affinée et a décliner de
manière plus opérationnelle et nous
recommandons d'intégrer dans le prochain
contrat d'objectifs performance des
objectifs et des indicateurs déficiences
chiffrées
enfin j'en aurai bientôt terminé
la gouvernance nous considérons que
le conseil d'administration n'a qu'une
faible impulsion sur le pilotage
stratégique de l'agence et nous le
regrettons le conseil d'administration
n'a pas participé à l'élaboration du
contrat d'objectifs et de performance il
l'a validé certes mais il n'a pas
participé à son élaboration et il y a
peu de débats en conseil
d'administration sur les orientations
stratégiques de SPF
il y a une prédominance de délibération
sur des sujets budgétaires ou sur des
questions administratives mais la
stratégie elle-même est singulièrement
absente des débats du conseil
d'administration
le Conseil Scientifique joue quant à lui
un rôle effectif mais incomplet
[Musique]
et le comité d'orientation et de et de
dialogue reste très discret
et c'est un peu un rendez-vous manqué
avec l'agence
enfin dernière slide sur les relations
avec la tutelle et les ARS
elles sont à conforter et
a prioriser
nous avons pointé une insuffisance
hiérarchisation des missions par le
ministère de la Santé
nous avons constaté par exemple un
cadrement du nombre de demandes de la
DGS entre 2019 et 2022 qui sont passés
de 20 20 demandes faites à SPF à 88
sans priorisation entre elles
et dans le même temps le ministère
demande à SPF de prioriser ses activités
mais sans prioriser lui-même ces
demandes à SPF donc on voit bien qu'il y
a une clarification une priorisation à
faire à la fois côté ministère de la
Santé et côté SPF
c'est la raison pour laquelle la cour
recommande d'assortir les programmes
annuels de travail d'une estimation
chiffrée des moyens humains et
budgétaires et de proposition de
priorisation liées au degré de sévérité
ou de l'état des maladies
sur la formulation des recommandations
par respect nous considérons que
l'expertise est trop peu utilisée
l'expertise est partagée avec d'autres
structures comme le Haut Conseil de la
santé publique comme l'enses l'Inca la
NSM
mais elle est insuffisamment mobilisée
par les pouvoirs publics
le comité d'animation du système
d'agence un rôle extrêmement limité et
il peine à exister
finalement entre des relations
bilatérales
entre les agences relation bilatérales
qui se sont qui ont été confortés
d'ailleurs par la crise sanitaire et
puis les travaux confiés au HCSP le
comité d'animation interagence à peine à
trouver sa place enfin
sur l'articulation entre les cellules
régionales de santé publique France et
les ARS
nous considérons
que il n'y aurait pas de plus-value
évidente à rattacher les cellules
régionales de SPF France de SPF
aux ARS autrement dit la vie même ou les
avis même des directeurs d'Ars directeur
général d'Ars rencontrés par l'équipe de
contrôle sont
très partagées sur cette question là et
nous considérons nous que le statut quo
en la matière est préférable à
l'expérimentation d'un
rattachement
dont il n'est pas sûr qu'on pourrait
attendre une plus-value voilà pardon
j'en ai terminé je vous remercie
merci madame la Présidente je vous
demande à tous un petit peu d'astention
et un petit peu de silence parce qu'il y
a un espèce de bruit de fond assez
désagréable
je donne la parole maintenant à Madame
Marianne Jacquet directrice générale par
intérim de santé publique France
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrice et sénateurs je
me propose peut-être de répondre aux
quelques points saillants qui viennent
d'être si vous voulez bien qui vient
d'être présenté par par la Cour des
comptes sans prétendre évidemment à
l'exhaustivité peut-être un point de
rappel au préalable donc je j'assure
l'intérim de la direction générale de
santé publique France depuis que les
professeurs Geneviève chêne donc
professeur de santé publique à achevé
son mandat donc le 30 octobre dernier
Amanda très riche vous le savez depuis
qu'elle a pris ses fonctions fin 2019
puisque elle a de fait connu la deuxième
partie de l'histoire de l'agence
souligné par la Cour qui est celle de la
gestion d'une pandémie exceptionnelle
même si je constate que les rapports de
les conseils de la cour portent aussi ce
qui est intéressant sur
l'agence également avant la crise à
partir de 2016 et moi-même j'ai rejoint
l'agence en comme directrice générale
adjointe en avril 2020
peut-être très rapidement et après on
sera pour répondre à vos questions
évidemment si je commence par la
question de la stratégie et de la
priorisation qui revient dans dans les
propos de la cour et dans dans le
rapport je voulais souligner que on
travaille évidemment de concerts avec la
Direction générale de la santé et le
ministre pour
comment développer une prorisation
peut-être plus explicite qu'elle ne
l'est si on suit le rapport sur les
priorités de l'agence je crois que le
rapport le souligne il y avait certes 28
programmes au début les programmes
foisonnants néanmoins la Cour dans son
rapport le souligne aussi on a quand
même dès 2020 la direction générale et
en parallèle de toutes ces missions qui
n'ont monopolisées sur la gestion de la
crise entre prix un travail de
resserrement de tout son programme
autour de 6 enjeux au lieu de 26 de 26
26 programmes auparavant avec la
nécessité de relier ces priorités de
santé publique au fardeau des maladies
puisque on agit vous le savez avant tout
sur les principaux déterminants de santé
qui sont bien connus et qui demeurent
universel et qui sont le tabagisme
notamment la consommation excessive
d'alcool le défaut d'activité physique
ou avant même la mauvaise alimentation
et donc c'est dans ce continuum que nous
sommes inscrits et toute activité de
l'agence est centrée en tout cas
beaucoup sur sur ces déterminants de
santé je tenais le souligner parce que
ça montre quand même le continuum qui a
été souligné par la Cour entre nos
missions de surveillance et celle de
prévention et de promotion de la santé
toujours sur le cadre stratégique de
l'agence cela a été évoqué nous
travaillons évidemment un nouveau Cope
contrat d'objectifs et de performance
pour 2023 et les 5 ans 5 ans qui suivent
et nous l'avons d'ailleurs partagé avec
les rapporteurs de la cour nous
souscrivons évidemment totalement à
l'objectif d'avoir un Cope cette fois-ci
qui soit fondé sur des objectifs
opérationnels et des indicateurs
chiffrés je pense que c'est une
préoccupation effondrée également sur la
nouvelle stratégie nationale de santé et
c'est dans ce sens que nous travaillons
avec le ministère et la Direction
générale de la santé
peut-être en ce qui concerne
plus précisément donc les
les trois volets de mission qui ont été
qui ont été qui ont été
abordés donc sur la surveillance de
l'état de santé des populations je
voulais peut-être préciser la lecture du
rapport que
l'agence c'est également très présente
c'est peut-être moins d'écrit mais sur
toutes ces missions de surveillance
également sur les expositions
environnementales professionnelles les
maladies chroniques non transmissibles
et en ce sens voilà l'agence est quand
même comment très présente avec une
expertise interne qui est extrêmement
développée qu'il ne faut pas oublier un
produit énormément de rapport d'études
d'articles scientifiques et de bulletins
également épidémiologiques comme vous le
savez en ce qui concerne la prévention
promotion de la santé peut-être un point
rapide sur ce qui a été ce qui est
ce qui a été dit évidemment nous
souscrivons totalement la nécessité
c'est ce qu'on a réactionné de
développer le référentiel des actions
prometteuses et probantes il a été
effectivement un petit peu retardé mais
je me permets de le signaler aussi parce
que nous avons eu en 2020-2021 et début
2022 une activité que vous n'ignorez pas
extrêmement présente sur la gestion de
la crise covid
et donc en ce qui concerne ce
référentiel des actions prometteuses et
probantes un comité d'experts a été
nommé et on se doit évidemment de mettre
à disposition des actions
évaluer scientifiquement qui soit
extrêmement qui soit facile à déployer
sur le terrain pour aussi soutenir de
manière très pragmatique la priorité
accordée par par le gouvernement à la
prévention
peut-être un point également sur
l'autre
sur des priorités je reviens pardon sur
la prévention promotion de la santé
vous soulignez madame a continuum qui a
été constaté mais qui est en cours de
consolidation entre la PPS et la
surveillance vous citez aussi la santé
mentale alors je me permets quand même
de préciser que la santé mentale elle a
quand même été vraiment mis en avant par
la Direction Générale de Santé Publique
France en 2020 on a quand même alerté
les autorités sur l'importance de ce
sujet notamment dans un contexte de
pandémie qui aura un impact important
l'étude covip-prêve elle est sortie des
mars 2020 on a sorti évidemment beaucoup
à publier de de bulletins sur sur ce
sujet et vous le savez aussi on a lancé
en partenariat avec l'Éducation
saluer qui a été utile en tout cas on
l'espère dans le dans la crise en ce qui
concerne la réserve sanitaire
cette fois-ci
là aussi quelques mots rapides on
souscrit évidemment à tous les constats
on a on a contribué avec le ministère
donc à réfléchir à une refonte de notre
stationnement de la réserve sanitaire
mais en tout cas une évolution de
l'ensemble du cadre de l'emploi des
renforts humains nécessaires en cas de
crise et pas seulement ce que l'on peut
dire c'est que vous le savez elle a
changé totalement d'échelle la réserve
sanitaire elle a été conçue comme étant
en mécanisme vraiment subsidiaire et un
des points structurels qu'il nous faut
aborder tous avec le ministère c'est que
ça a été dit aussi elle a quand même
pour caractéristique de puiser dans ces
viviers de renforts de trouver des
renforts dans un vivier qu'elle est
censée de pression de santé qu'elle est
censée soutenir et donc quand il y a un
défaut structurel de certains
professionnels qui sont mobilisés sur la
crise par définition il est difficile de
retrouver les réanimateurs de la réserve
nécessaire pour venir la renforcer et
pour pour terminer sur le sujet de la
réserve sanitaire évidemment il faut
réfléchir à un cadre plus global sur
l'ensemble des renforts humains à
apporter selon les situations et
lesquelles
selon que l'on est dans une situation
nationale ou au contraire régionale
évidemment les systèmes d'information
sont très importants et j'y reviendrai
tout à l'heure
en ce qui concerne la gestion des stocks
stratégiques là aussi
je pense que c'était pas l'objet
principal du rapport de la Cour mais
vous n'ignorez pas évidemment
l'importance des de l'activité de cette
activité pour santé publique France en
2020 c'est voilà c'est 4,5 milliards de
masques commandés distribués pour plus
de 2 milliards partout sur le territoire
national c'est un milliard 800 millions
d'autres équipements de protection
individuels qui ont été stockés achetés
sont des nouveaux médicaments de
réanimation qui ont été au traitement
innovants qui continuent d'être
distribués jusqu'à la maille la plus
fine et c'est évidemment toute la
logistique vaccinale avec l'acquisition
l'achat la distribution jusqu'ici on a
distribué plus de 190 millions de doses
de vaccins covid jusqu'au mails les plus
fines du territoire avec un portail de
commandes auprès tous les professionnels
de santé et dans des conditions
logistiques pharmaceutiques que vous
connaissez sont très particulières avec
du froid négatif sur les ARN messagers
et je voudrais aussi souligner voilà le
continuum nécessaire entre cette gestion
stock et nos compétences
épidémiologiques qui a toujours été très
présente au quotidien dans la crise même
dans les crises puisqu'on la vie aussi
quand on a dû répondre à la notamment
cet été à la variole du singe et à la
crise du handicapé
et évidemment nous avons partagé avec la
cour et le ministère la nécessité de
rénover le cadre d'emploi de ce stock
des stratégique qui doit évidemment être
une réflexion là aussi collective
impliquant plusieurs plusieurs acteurs
ce qu'on a commencé à faire
peut-être sans être trop longue
je pense que vous avez oui les systèmes
d'information peut-être je voudrais
insister sur les systèmes d'information
c'est vrai qu'on avait des alors
le rythme de modernisation des systèmes
d'information et souligné comme étant
insuffisant alors je n'étais pas
personnellement là la première période
de la l'activité de l'agence je voudrais
quand même souligner que la fusion de 4
structures
préexistant de nature très différentes
avec et quand même quelque chose qu'il
faut qu'il faut pouvoir travailler et ça
a été un gros travail des équipes à la
création de l'agence pour pouvoir
cartographier homogénéiser unifier ces
systèmes d'information
l'infogérance a été réalisée également
avant la crise et ensuite il est vrai
que on a eu des systèmes d'information
qui se sont avérés obsolètes qu'on a
modernisé assez vite je dois le
souligner que la crise sanitaire a été
de la
covid a été quand même un accélérateur
et à catalyseur énorme pour pouvoir
moderniser ces systèmes
et voilà les crédits budgétaires nous
ont officiel aussi été alloués
maintenant on peut avoir moderniser
l'outil la réserve sanitaire on peut
moderniser aussi l'outil les outils et
de comment de l'établissement
pharmaceutique on peut moderniser aussi
sursaut le fameux système de
surveillance qui a été cité par la Cour
et qui effectivement qui est
indispensable de moderniser et au-delà
de ça je voudrais appeler votre
attention sur
la période nécessité effectivement de
capitaliser sur des systèmes de
surveillance réactif je pense que c'est
l'un des enseignements majeurs de la
gestion de cette pandémie on a besoin de
système de surveillance qui soit réactif
opérationnel et qui implique tout le
monde c'est-à-dire que c'est un système
de surveillance qui doit capter assez
précocément des données au plus près de
là où sont ces données c'est-à-dire dans
les services de réanimation des hôpitaux
par exemple dans les établissements
médico-sociaux
et il y a eu des grandes réussites
pendant la crise comme si DEP comme taxi
et je pense qu'on a tous évidemment un
devoir de pouvoir pérenniser capitaliser
ces systèmes qui concerne évidemment
plusieurs acteurs des pas seulement la
l'agence sanitaire de santé publique
France
je vous remercie merci Madame la
Directrice pour terminer nous entendons
Madame Catherine grenier directrice et
assurées de la Caisse nationale
d'assurance maladie financière de
l'agence
madame la Présidente
messieurs et mesdames les sénates et
sénatrices d'abord je voulais vous
remercier pour une invitation de
l'assurance maladie et puis vous vous
excusez notre représentation partielle
puisque la direction des Finances n'a
pas pu être présente donc moi je suis la
directrice des assurés je vais pouvoir
vous parler de la collaboration que la
que l'assurance maladie a avec santé
publique France sur des aspects à la
fois épidémiologiques et en prévention
promotion de la santé donc d'abord déjà
se mettre bien sûr en
lien avec ce qui a été dit sur les
systèmes d'information de la crise et
tous les travaux qui ont pu être
réalisés sur le contact tracing sur le
criblage des différents virus qui qui
ont été réalisées en collaboration entre
les deux instances entre les deux
institution pardon et puis plus
généralement un certain nombre de
projets thématiques ou populationnels
sur lesquels nous travaillons
collectivement à la fois dans le cadre
du fond de lutte contre les addictions
avec de une convention importante entre
le santé publique française et la CNAM
sur le marketing social avec des
applications en particulier sur le tabac
mais sur également d'autres facteurs
comportementaux de risque les travaux
sur les dépistages des cancers sur
lesquels nous travaillons sur les
mesures de taux de couverture de taux de
participation dans une coordination
soutenue avec santé publique France et
on participe ensemble au comité
stratégique qui est menée par la
Direction générale de la santé
sur la grille pour la ou la ou
l'assurance maladie est en charge des
campagnes on a une participation au
comité de pilotage de santé publique
France et la collaboration se fait aussi
sur la les mesures de taux de couverture
vaccinale de la même façon c'est un
petit peu des allers-retours entre les
deux institutions sur les autres
vaccinations la CNAM se fait le relais
des campagnes de communication de santé
publique France sur les différents gros
sujets je vais pas tous les citer ici
mais les 1000 premiers jours la
stratégie jeune l'antibiorésistance les
travaux sur les gestes barrières et
aujourd'hui les gestes universels il y a
aussi ses collaborations entre les entre
les deux institutions il y a un volet
recherche à ses collaborations également
avec les travaux sur la coord constance
la les études entraide sur le diabète
les études qui sont réalisées sur
l'avancée en âge notamment sur la
mortalité en EHPAD ou sur les
hospitalisations spécifiquement pour
syndrome
gériatrique un certain nombre d'autres
sujets comme les maladies
cardiovasculaires sont également
abordés et puis peut-être
insister aussi sur les l'enjeu de
communication sur lequel un relais se
construit bien nous semble-t-il entre
les campagnes de santé publique France
et ce que la l'assurance maladie peut
faire à la fois portée au niveau du
grand public via ces outils type Amélie
ou compte assuré précisément vis-à-vis
des professionnels de santé également
puisque nous avons la possibilité
d'adresser des messages à tous les
professionnels de santé et puis
peut-être plus spécifiquement sur les
enjeux de prévention le travail que nous
faisons dans les centres d'examens de
santé avec les outils de santé publique
France qui sont aussi
vis-à-vis des des assurés qui viennent
en consultation dans les dans les
centres d'examen de santé et des
professionnels de santé sur sur cette
spécificité les travaux d'ailleurs qui
sont réalisés aujourd'hui qui sont en
cours sur les rendez-vous de prévention
aux âges de la vie
contribue à cette collaboration et
les travaux s'appuient notamment sur le
site qui a été développé par santé
publique France sur le Bien vieillir et
donc le sujet va être de voir comment on
articule ces auto-évaluations qui
peuvent être à disposition du grand
public et la manière dont on les invite
à participer à ces rendez-vous de
prévention
voilà ce que je pouvais dire
si Madame la Directrice
nous avons une inscription une demande
de prise de parole pour l'instant
monsieur ça fait trois ah oui oui pardon
la première Madame Corinne Imbert
rapporteur pour la branche maladie
merci madame le Président merci Madame
la présente de la cour mesdames les
directrices
ça commence en musique trop fort
[Rires]
ça va peut-être
mais mes propos vont peut-être
[Rires]
bon
donc mes propos vont peut-être un peu
plomber plomber l'ambiance mais
qui démarrez bien vous le reconnaître
oui parce que ce rapport madame à
présente me laisse un peu sur sur ma
faim
en effet la Cour ne formule aucune
recommandation explicite en matière de
gestion de stock stratégique
d'adossements à la recherche en matière
de gouvernance mais en matière de
mobilisation de l'expertise par des
pouvoirs publics comment j'allais dire
expliquer cette timidité vous le dites
vous-même la stratégie reste à clarifier
la Cour ne tranche pas non plus le débat
relatif à la présence territoriale de
l'agence et la territorialisation de la
veille sanitaire
excusez-moi
puisque vous désapprouvez implicitement
la proposition faisait le rapport de la
commission d'enquête sanatoriale sur la
gestion de la crise covid relative au
rattachement aux ARS et c'est le
territoriales de SPF vous prenez le
statut quo pouvez-vous préciser la
position de la Cour sur ce point et les
échanges que vous dites dans le rapport
avoir eu avec les directeurs généraux
des ARS
une remarque sur la réserve sanitaire
puisque vous évoquez une réserve
sanitaire au cadre à rénover alors je
crois que nous étions un certain nombre
de sénateurs inquiets de la fusion des 4
agences dont les Prusse au moment de la
création de santé publique France et
votre affirmation une réserve sanitaire
au cadre à rénovée n'est-ce pas la
simple conséquence justement de la
fusion des quatre agences dont les
Prusse au moment de la création de SPF
je crois que c'était une de nos craintes
à l'époque malheureusement la crise est
passée par là et n'a révélé que les
inquiétudes que nous avions à l'époque
vous vous mentionnez également un
recours à des prestataires pour la
gestion des stocks et la logistique
avez-vous une idée du coût de ce recours
aux prestataires pour ces deux points
Madame la Directrice c'est vrai que vous
avez noté que l'état des stocks
stratégiques par n'était pas l'essentiel
du rapport mais en cas de crise vous le
savez bien c'est quand même l'inquiétude
une inquiétude de nos concitoyens et ce
qui nous préoccupe nous en tant que
sénateur
juste également par rapport à vos propos
je souscris évidemment au fait que
SIDEP a bien fonctionné vous avez été
assez réactif sur la création de ce
système et ça fonctionne bien j'ai noté
également et je m'écar du rapport mais
c'est par rapport j'y reviendrai mais
par rapport aux interventions notamment
de l'assurance maladie sur la bonne
collaboration entre la CNAM et SPF
heureusement j'allais dire le comble
serait de constaté le contraire alors
que la sécurité sociale finance l'agence
alors si je reviens au rapport sur
l'autonomie de l'agence et sa relation
avec la tutelle pourriez-vous s'il vous
plaît la présidente de la cour
préciser à qui vous estimez que devrait
être incomber le pilotage stratégique de
SPF
dans le rapport swing bien qu'il
s'exerce sur des missions de nature
différente lesquelles requiert plus ou
moins de capacités décisionnelles de son
conseil d'administration en matière de
gouvernance de la politique de santé
quelle conclusion faut-il en tirer sur
les missions de santé publique France
voir sur la place de l'agence dans le
paysage administratif et institutionnel
une nouvelle répartition des missions
avec les autres agences est-elle
souhaitable
sur les comparaisons avec les homologues
étrangers de santé publique France vous
le notez elles sont difficiles à faire
un ou plusieurs modèles étrangers
néanmoins de se dégage-t-il pas des
observations de la Cour au fil de son
enquête
enfin une question semble absente du
rapport
et elle concerne la déontologie la
gestion des conflits d'intérêts l'une
des premières observations faites par
santé publique France elle-même à la
mission d'information de la commission
des affaires sociales sur la lutte
contre l'obésité a été en forme
d'avertissement pour préciser que
l'industrie du sucre comme celle du
tabac et je cite à orienter des
recherches pour instiller le doute sur
la dangereuse dangerosité de leurs
produits et inventer les avantages de
l'auto-régulation les stratégies
d'influence sont les mêmes quel que soit
les secteurs la cour s'est-elle penchée
sur les moyens par lesquels SPF peut
contribuer à assainir l'expertise
scientifique voilà je m'arrêterai là je
vous remercie toutes les trois pour vos
interventions
merci Madame lehouet roux en
remplacement de Madame Elisabeth
Doisneau rapporteur général merci madame
la Présidente effectivement j'interviens
en préalable des travaux que nous devons
conduire avec Elisabeth douanot
rapporteur général et en son absence je
porte donc ces interrogations ces
questions s'inscrivent dans la suite
d'initiative que le Sénat a prise dans
le cadre des derniers PLFSS en matière
de dotation de la sécurité sociale à
d'autres organismes comme cela a été
rappelé les dotations de la sécurité
sociale à la santé publique France
effectuée au moyen d'arrêter ministériel
ont été un véhicule privilégié pour les
dépenses publiques en réponse à la crise
sanitaire non seulement en 2020 quand la
crise a surpris tout le monde mais aussi
les années suivantes la Cour des comptes
semble montrer dans son enquête une
certaine compréhension pour ce procédé
les arrêtés ministériales voire pour le
procédé ayant consisté à reverser une
partie significative de cette dotation
au travers de fonds de concours
pourriez-vous préciser en quoi ces
crédits présentaient une nature
différente de ceux qui émanaient de
l'État et qui ont donné lieu à de
multiples collectifs budgétaires en 2020
et 2022 en quoi ne devait-il pas relever
du principe d'autorisation des pensées
publiques de manière générale au vu de
la nature des missions et des dépenses
de santé publique France vous
semble-t-il cohérent que les dotations
respectives de l'État et de la sécurité
sociale à santé publique France toutes
deux prévus par la loi soit
respectivement donc de 0% pour l'État et
100% pour la sécurité sociale qu'elle
pourrait être une clé de répartition
plus logique la modification de
l'identité du financeur en 2020 sécurité
sociale au lieu de l'État s'est-elle
traduite par une modification de la
gouvernance de santé publique France
se répartissent les rôles entre l'État
et la sécurité sociale en matière de
gouvernance et de décision aux yeux de
la Cour ne devrait-il pas y avoir un
lien entre financeur et décideurs et
puis j'avais une question à titre plus
personnelle on a parlé de des stocks de
protection individuelles du
renouvellement des stocks alors je sais
pas si ça relève de la Cour des comptes
mais lors de la crise covid nous nous
sommes rendus compte que il y avait des
difficultés d'approvisionnement et que
par exemple pour les masses il y avait
en quantité mais il y a aussi il y avait
aussi en approvisionnement beaucoup
d'entreprises françaises se sont
développées pour produire des masques on
contacte on constate aujourd'hui
qu'elles sont en difficulté et que nous
sommes inondés de masques venant de
Chine et d'ailleurs donc quid de la
préférence nationale et qu'elle position
peut avoir santé publique France pour
garantir que
que demain nous aurons à nouveau une
crise avec des barrières internationales
la production française pourra assurer
la production de masse merci je prends
cet exemple
merci je vous propose madame la
Présidente de répondre
tout d'abord à nos deux rapporteurs
avant de donner la parole à nos
collègues inscrits
merci madame la Présidente alors sur la
première question de Madame Humbert
alors question gigogne
sur le fait que nous n'ayons pas formulé
de recommandations explicite sur les
stocks stratégiques sur la gouvernance
sur l'organisation territoriale etc nous
n'avons pas fait de recommandations en
revanche nous avons
détaillé dans le rapport un certain
nombre de constats
sur la gestion des stocks stratégiques
il faut mettre en balance l'intérêt de
santé publique et la dépense publique
est en résulte il y a des arbitrages à
prendre
notamment en matière de renouvellement
des stocks
surtout des stocks de d'équipements de
protection individuel
des au niveau de la dotation budgétaire
de SPF qui doit en résulter tout ça est
entre les mains et doit être entre les
mains de du ministère de la santé c'est
bien à l'État qu'il revient c'est ce que
je disais tout à l'heure dans ma
présentation d'être garant que le niveau
des stocks stratégiques correspond aux
besoins qu'il a identifié face aux
crises sanitaires
quitte à en confier les aspects
logistiques à un opérateur en
l'occurrence SPF et il sera intéressant
d'ailleurs à cet égard de voir les
recommandations et les propositions que
fera Cécile courage qui a été donc
missionné
pour pour la création d'une Direction de
préparation et de gestion des crises
sur la la gouvernance
la cour je l'ai dit tout à l'heure
considère que la composition du conseil
d'administration de santé publique
France n'appelle pas de modification
mais elle regrette que
le positionnement du conseil
d'administration soit assez en retrait
sur les questions stratégiques c'est ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure donc je n'y
reviens pas
sur
la
territorialisation là aussi j'en ai dit
quelques mots
nous avons donc eu des échanges enfin
l'équipe de rapporteur a eu des échanges
avec plusieurs directeurs généraux d'Ars
et les avis sont partagés sur
le rattachement ou pas des cellules
territoriales de SPF aux ARS
certes le DG DRS Auvergne Rhône-Alpes
ces homologues des pays des Pays de la
Loire et des Hauts-de-France sont
beaucoup plus nuancés sur la sur la
question et donc ce qui est certain
c'est que ces cellules régionales
doivent être à la fois présentes sur le
terrain
et rester en lien fort et trois avec SPF
si ça peut fonctionner comme ça
fonctionne aujourd'hui nous considérons
qu'il n'y a pas matière à une
réorganisation systémique
sur
pardon la réserve sanitaire
la cour vous rejoint dans vos dans vos
remarques sur le fait que la crise a
révélé les craintes qu'on pouvait avoir
auparavant
le cadre d'emploi et le de la réserve
sanitaire est à revoir complètement les
rémunérations qui sont allouées aux
réservistes ont à revoir complètement
l'organisation l'organisation est à
revoir complètement et voilà on
n'a pas de on a une recommandation
là-dessus mais qui invite à une mise à
plat complète par les pouvoirs publics
de cet outil de réserve sanitaire qui a
montré à la fois sans son son utilité
sa grande utilité dans la dans la crise
sanitaire mais également ça les grandes
difficultés qui se sont posées pour pour
l'activer et et qu'elle soit à la
hauteur de des enjeux de la crise
sur le prestataire de SPF sur la gestion
des des stocks
alors nous mentionnons ce point dans le
rapport le SPF donc fait appel à un
cabinet conseil
pour un total de 7 millions d'euros
puisque la question a été posée de
savoir combien ça avait coûté donc c'est
7 millions d'euros
et le marché le plus important à lui
porter sur les prestations d'appui
opérationnel c'est-à-dire de logistique
et de distribution de produits de santé
pour 3 millions 4
donc voilà les chiffres que nous avons
alors ce qui m'amène à
vous informer de ce que
ça n'était pas au coeur du rapport que
d'examiner les les
marchés conclus par le mystère de la
santé ou par respect avec des cabinets
conseils notamment ou des prestataires
au sens large
le
Sénat a publié un rapport assez complet
sur la question et la Cour des comptes
va prochainement publier également un
rapport sur cette question du recours
par l'État aux prestations de conseil
alors
sur alors je suis un peu perdu
voilà
sur
le pilotage stratégique de santé
publique France
alors on a bien en termes d'organisation
interne on a un conseil d'administration
on a vu qu'il se penchait insuffisamment
sur les questions d'orientation
stratégique mais on a un conseil
d'administration et qui est là pour
décider en termes plus large et
notamment de dialogue avec l'État c'est
le ministère de la Santé qui porte la
première responsabilité du pilotage
stratégique avec la DGS bien sûr la DSS
pour ce qui est très aux aspects
budgétaires
donc l'efficacité du pilotage
stratégique elle passe essentiellement
et avant tout par une bonne coordination
entre les instances de SPF et les
grandes directions du ministère de la
Santé concernée sur la gouvernance de la
politique de santé
j'ai dit tout à l'heure un mot du Casa
qui contribue très peu finalement à
l'élaboration de la politique nationale
de santé au choix d'orientation
prioritaire dans le champ de la de la
prévention de la promotion de la santé
pour autant nous n'avons pas identifié à
l'occasion de ce rapport de
problématique particulière de périmètre
de compétences entre les agences
puisqu'il y avait ça cette question
sous-jacente
nous n'avons pas identifié de
difficultés particulières
sur les comparaisons avec nos homologues
et étrangers de SPF
comme je l'ai dit la création elle-même
de santé publique France a été inspirée
par les modèles britanniques américains
et canadiens notamment
pour autant
il a été difficile de d'aller trop loin
dans les comparaisons tant les le champ
des compétences des uns et des autres
sont difficilement comparables et tant
était difficile l'accès notamment aux
données de comptabilité analytique
un point important quand même sur le sur
la différence entre SPF et C et ses
homologues étrangers c'est sur
l'intégration ou pas de la recherche des
activités de recherche on voit que dans
les chez les Allemands par exemple ou
chez les Américains on a des modèles
avec des activités de recherche intégrée
ce qui n'est pas le cas de de SPF
c'est la raison pour laquelle
c'est la raison pour laquelle il est il
est fondamental que SPF conserve des
liens forts avec le secteur de la
recherche et que
voilà il y a une bonne une bonne
articulation entre la recherche et SPF
sur la déontologie alors là aussi ça
n'était pas l'objet du rapport que de se
pencher sur la question des conflits
d'intérêt même si c'est une question
importante bien sûr dans l'expertise
sanitaire et elle a été examinée par la
course cette question particulière du
conflit d'intérêt notamment dans
l'expertise sanitaire dans un rapport
qui date un peu aujourd'hui mais qui
avait été remis à votre commission et
qui était un rapport de 2016
mais comme il date un peu c'est une
question sur laquelle on reviendra sans
doute assez rapidement
mais ont donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle en tout cas on n'a pas creusé
ce point particulier dans le rapport de
de SPF France de de santé biblique
France pardon
même si c'est un vrai sujet
auquel on est extrêmement attentif
sur les questions alors
relative
dotation de l'État et de la sécurité
sociale donc le poids respectif de
l'État et de la sécurité sociale à la
santé publique France
on n'a pas de d'incohérence le fait
d'imputer le financement de SPF à la
sécurité sociale plutôt qu'à enfin
l'assurance maladie plutôt qu'à à l'état
n'étant soient pas problématique selon
nous dès lors qu'il y a un financeur
unique qui est sans doute préférable du
point de vue de la simplicité des
circuits budgétaires des circuits
financiers qu'on peut en attendre
et après tout
[Rires]
[Musique]
et sur l'incidence que ça pourrait avoir
sur
sur la gouvernance de SPF là non plus
nous ne sommes pas proposé de
modification et nous constatons que ça
fonctionne ailleurs par exemple ça
fonctionne pour pour la NSM qui est dans
le même le même schéma avec un
financement assurance maladie et un
une gouvernance
qui n'est pas de l'assurance maladie et
un président de conseil d'administration
qui est nommé par par l'État et qui
d'ailleurs est auditionné par les par
les commissions des affaires sociales
des deux assemblées donc
rien rien ne nous gêne là dedans entre
dans ce le principe d'une d'un
découplage entre financeurs et décideur
au fond c'est se découplage il est fait
dans de nombreux domaines on pourrait
dire la même chose sur la politique
hospitalière les hôpitaux
relèvent d'un financement assurance
maladie et pourtant
ils sont bien ils sont bien ils relèvent
bien enfin la politique hospitalière
relève bien de l'État donc voilà ça nous
semble pas poser un problème en tant que
tel
dès lors que tout ça est bien organisé
et coordonné
question qui ont été posées également
[Musique]
sur le renouvelle
sur le renouvellement des stocks je
laisserai plutôt
madame Jacquet répondent
il me semble avoir fait le tour des
questions j'espère ne pas en avoir
oublié parfait madame merci madame la
présidente madame Jacquet
oui merci madame la Présidente peut-être
pour répondre madame la rapporteur sur
la question spécifique qui m'était
adressée sur la
le renouvellement des stocks et
notamment si j'ai bien compris le la
question des achats de des achats de
masse dans le cadre d'une souveraineté
nationale française
madame lehouérou c'est pour vous et
peut-être vous répondre commencez par
vous répondre sur la question spécifique
des masques alors évidemment on
renouvelle le stock stratégique état de
manière continue sur l'ensemble de ces
produits pas seulement en réponse
d'ailleurs à la pandémie de la covid
mais face à tous les risques identifiés
en ce qui concerne donc les masques de
protection et votre question nous avons
donc à qui un nombre de masques déjà
très important qui est encore dans nos
stocks mais nous avons lancé donc
récemment un sur demande du ministère un
appel d'offres pour acquérir 200
millions de masques à la fois
chirurgicaux et FFP2 pour renouveler ce
stock et dans ce cadre nous avons
évidemment cette préoccupation
de pouvoir avoir d'une part plusieurs
fournisseurs pour des raisons de
sécurité d'approvisionnement aussi et
dans des sécurités sanitaires et
évidemment en proximité également ce qui
rejoint votre questionnement sur la
capacité à s'appuyer sur les forces de
production française qui se sont
développées pendant la crise et donc
pour cela nous avons évidemment
respecter toutes les orientations
réfléchies par y compris par le
ministère des Finances pour pouvoir dans
le respect de la commande publique qui
s'impose à nous entre coopérateurs de
l'État effectivement renforcer cette
cette dimension donc ça veut dire
concrètement que on a appliqué un
critère prix de 20%
seulement dans l'ensemble de la notation
que évidemment le on va respecter le
comment le cas de la commande publique
qui est évite tout dumping et puis on a
évidemment toutes les clauses de
responsabilité sociale environnementale
qui sont qui sont dans ces marchés et on
a opéré auparavant à sourcing assez
complet
sur auprès des entreprises et qui ont
répondu d'ailleurs de manière très très
constructive
peut-être si vous me permettez sur les
quelques autres points qui ont été
soulignés je voulais peut-être
intervenir sur les cellules régionales
puisque la question était posée je
voudrais quand même souligner que les
cellules régionales c'est la
représentation dans les territoires
comme ça a été dit de l'Agence de santé
publique France qui est donc l'Agence
nationale de santé publique et je pense
que c'est aussi cette organisation c'est
le garant d'avoir une agence nationale
de santé publique forte et surtout une
unité dans nos méthodes de surveillance
et d'investigation pour être plus
concrète elles font partie de l'agence
parce qu'elles appliquent les méthodes
de référence scientifiques nécessaires
au suivi l'épidémiologie et on ne
pourrait pas accepter par exemple que le
taux d'incidence ou de prévalence d'une
maladie ou bien d'une émergence soit
calculer différemment en haut de France
en Bourgogne Franche-Comté en Bretagne
et donc se rattachement santé publique
France c'est aussi la garantie d'une
méthode scientifique de surveillance qui
soit homogène dans tous les territoires
ensuite évidemment elles sont là et elle
fonctionne de manière matricielle avec
les ARS pour pouvoir apporter un
éclairage au regard des besoins
territoriaux et les ARS sont demandés
aussi d'un éclairage particulier vu les
spécificités de leur territoire et c'est
là qu'il y a une dimension spécifique
des cellules régionales
et puis peut-être enfin sur cette trop
longue sur le les recours aux
prestataires alors Direction Générale de
Santé Publique France a eu l'occasion
d'être auditionné dans cette enceinte
enfin devant la mission sénatoriale sur
le sur le sujet comme s'était dit par la
Cour nous avons eu recours à des
prestataires mais de logistiques
purement opérationnels je tiens à le
dire qui n'était absolument pas dans le
pilotage stratégique et qui nous ont
aidé à faire notamment très concrètement
des études de réseaux pour redéployer
tout le réseau logistique c'était des
gens très techniques par exemple vous
savez qu'en 2020 on a dû quand même
ouvrir jusqu'à 23 plateformes en urgence
avec des études de réseaux logistiques
très pointus à conduire pour
l'établissement pharmaceutique je
rappelle qui compte qui comptait 10
personnes 10 personnes 10 personnes plus
de personnes mobilisées sur les achats
évidemment nous avions d'autres renforts
mais vu les masses qui représentent 12
milliards d'euros il y a quand même un
changement d'échelle inédit lié à cette
pandémie qui a qui a d'ailleurs mis le
monde le monde à l'arrêt
merci Madame les directrices Monsieur
Alain Milon à la parole
oui merci madame la Présidente
tout d'abord je voudrais vous remercier
pour votre rapport qui en fait
je sais pas si je peux le dire comme ça
mais reflète un peu ce que nous sentions
confusément sur le fonctionnement de
santé publique France depuis quelques
mois donc c'est avec une certaine
satisfaction que je reçois votre rapport
en disant finalement je me suis pas
vraiment trompé c'est ses premiers
points le deuxième point nous savons
tous que sentait plus 8 francs ça a été
créé par Marisol Touraine et que c'était
pour des raisons financières pour des
raisons de budget et que nous
regroupions dans santé publique France
l'impasse
l'InVS et Prusse
et si je regarde la façon dont sont
gérés les crises en lors de la crise
H1N1 un S et NVS et Prusse ont géré la
crise d'une manière admirable à tel
point d'ailleurs que la mise de l'époque
a été critiquée parce qu'elle avait trop
dépensé
et si on regarde cette fois-ci la crise
covid on s'aperçoit que cette gestion
qui avait été excellente tout au moins
bonne dans une crise H1N1 n'a pas été
aussi bonne dans la crise covid pour des
raisons que nous pourrions détailler qui
ne touchent pas les personnes mais qui à
mon avis touche l'organisation est-ce
que vous n'avez pas le sentiment
finalement que sentiez publique France
est un mastodonte quelque chose de
beaucoup trop gros un gros machin qui de
toute façon
n'arrivera jamais à fonctionner
complètement efficacement par rapport à
les Prusse par rapport à l'InVS ou à la
baisse que personnellement je regrette
question ensuite René Paul Savary oui
merci
on continue de la Milo moi je me demande
si on a vraiment tiré entièrement partie
de la crise qu'on vient de qu'on vient
de combien d'avoir il faudrait bien que
si jamais il y avait une nouvelle
épidémie on soit pas recommencer les
mêmes choses on est fait appel à un
prestataire à ce moment-là sur la
logistique pourquoi pas mais si ce
produit une crise maintenant on les
connaît les circuits donc après il y a
pas lieu me semble-t-il de refaire appel
à un prestataire et qui a fait le
prestataire il s'appuyait sur les élus
locaux et les départements pour savoir
comment comment on s'organiser dans dans
tout cela c'est on a répondu justement
aux prestataires et sont sur le terrain
derrière le préfet l'organisation
territoriale qui a permis de gagner du
temps moi je pense que il est important
que santé publique France est une
organisation territorialisée et
différentes selon les missions que vous
avez courante de la mission de crise il
faut impérativement me semble-t-il
postni contre de la crise d'avoir une
espèce de cellule de crise on avait
appelé ça sur un rapport une crise qui
permet de mobiliser toutes les forces
vives et derrière un seul un seul chef
qui est le préfet de département donc il
est important d'avoir cette gestion de
crise autour du préfet de département
avec la RS santé publique France la CNAM
parce qu'elle amène des choses et
d'autres
interlocuteurs tels que les départements
est-ce que vous avez cette configurer
une une
comment dire une gestion de crise aiguë
particulière à activer dans les 24
heures vous voyez on aurait un accident
un accident autour de les centrales
nucléaires est-ce que vous êtes capable
de donner dans les 24 heures des
comprimés diode et que vous connaissez
les circuits etc ce qu'on appelle
vraiment une cellule de crise derrière
et puis en ce qui concerne la gestion
des stocks moi j'ai un j'avais un ex
établissement des Prusse à
Vitry-le-François dans la Marne et au
moment de la crise on détruisait les
masques périmés alors qu'après on nous a
dit que finalement même s'ils étaient
périmés ils pourraient servir à des
acteurs de deuxième rang est-ce que vous
avez tenu compte également de tout cela
par rapport à la gestion des stocks
merci merci et pour conclure Madame A
poursu poli
oui merci madame la Présidente
concernant la Constitution et
l'entretien des stocks stratégiques j'ai
une petite question d'abord il faut
quand même se souvenir qu'en France 218
000 doses d'astrages
Zeneca ont été jetés à la poubelle en
raison de leur date de préemption
ce péremption péremption ah j'ai dit
préemption non je suis dans un autre
débat péremption selon donc la
directrice générale de la santé et cela
ressemble tout de même
210 218.000 doses à 2 euros l'unité ça
fait quand même
436000 euros de perdu
Pauline londex de l'Observatoire de la
transparence dans les politiques du
médicament avaient donc dénoncé qu'un
tiers de la population mondiale n'a reçu
aucune dose de vaccin
quand on voit les chiffres de gâchis on
peut être que choqué mais
malheureusement on pouvait s'y attendre
parce que les pays riches et bien
évidemment ont voulu accaparer les doses
de vaccin ayant peur dans manquer vous
l'en vacciner la population évidemment
rapidement ils ont acheté les doses et
ça a conduit à se gâchis je crois qu'il
y a quand même un problème récurrent
depuis le début de la crise du covid
c'est la question de la gestion des
stocks qui est une constante je pense
catastrophique alors quelle disposition
voilà ma question quelle disposition
était prise pour éviter la reproduction
de ces erreurs stratégiques de gestion
de stocks et après une insuffisance de
stock de masques pendant la pandémie le
sort des doses de vaccin non utilisé
réinterroge sur évidemment les prises de
décision à la Direction de santé
publique France je vous remercie
merci
madame la Présidente je répondrai à la
première question de d'Alain mignon et
puis je laisserai la parole pour les
deux autres questions à SPF France santé
publique France pardon
sur
SPF qui serait un gros machin pour
reprendre votre expression si c'est la
peur
pas forcément très efficace ou moins
efficace que je l'aurais été
les limpesses les Prusse et l'InVS
autant de h1
je suis pas sûr que ce soit la taille et
le regroupement des des établissements
qui font qu'un établissement est
efficace ou pas en tout cas si on
compare encore une fois avec ce qui se
passe à l'étranger on a des
établissements plus importants et qui ne
sont pas moins efficaces
et nettement plus important en taille et
en mission c'est la raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs les comparaisons étaient
difficilement réalisables donc voilà
méfions-nous des des
voilà de ce genre de comparaison si
tenter aussi que la situation sanitaire
puisse être comparable en cas de h1 et
en cas de pandémie mondiale
je ne suis pas du tout une spécialiste
de ces questions là et donc je laisserai
de plus compétent que moi répondre mais
voilà juste sur sur la le gros machin ça
n'est pas le gros machin qui fait que ou
pas et voilà je pense qu'on a aussi à
apprendre de l'étranger il y a de beaux
exemples de gros machins qui
fonctionnent merci merci
et donc je l'ai la parole madame Jacquet
pour répondre à Monsieur Savary et à
Madame poursu poli
oui merci madame la Présidente pour
commencer sur cette première question
alors je pense qu'il y a un sujet quand
même de taille critique à avoir pour
pouvoir répondre à des pandémies d'une
ampleur qui est quand même inégalée je
pense que la covid 19 est quand même une
épidémie d'une ampleur inégalée et qui
n'a pas de comparaison dans un avenir
dans un dans un passé dans un passé
précédent et il faut quand même un
minimum de taille critique pour pouvoir
avoir l'assise nécessaire les renforts
mutualiser les personnes les faire
tourner parce que c'est une crise qui
est une ampleur absolument
exceptionnelle et qui surtout
caractéristiques de s'inscrire dans la
durée donc d'ailleurs ce sont des hommes
des femmes qui se sont mobilisés sans
discontinuer pendant deux ans avec
d'ailleurs les ARS la direction générale
et la santé ou la CNAM et d'ailleurs il
faut des forces vives et une capacité de
solidarité interne d'organisation
interne de mutualisation qui me
semble-t-il aurait été beaucoup plus
difficile avec un morcellement des des
compétences par ailleurs
santé publique France peut paraître un
mastodonte néanmoins je constate à la
lecture des rapports de la Cour qui a
des mastodontes encore plus importants
et bien plus important dans les autres
pays ce qui veut bien dire que la taille
peut quand même être aussi importante
dans l'accomplissement de toutes ces
missions de santé publique qui je le
répète ce sont des missions essentielles
de santé publique qui sont référencés à
l'international dans le référentiel OMS
comme des missions de santé publique
avec un continuum
ensuite pour vous répondre sur la
logistique et l'organisation
monsieur sénateur sur l'organisation
comment territoriale et le lien avec les
préfets et les élus et dans la gestion
de crise alors oui évidemment santé
publique France c'est dans ces missions
première est organisée pour réagir en 24
heures à une gestion de crise et
j'ajouterai qu'évidemment elle ne le
fait pas seul puisqu'elle fait partie
d'un écosystème d'acteurs de gestion de
crise a commencé par évidemment le
ministère de la Santé qui aurait pu
s'exprimer sur la question on est en
lien permanent toutes les heures avec le
de crise du ministère du ministère de la
Santé et de manière plus générale on
inscrit nos plans vous parliez de l'iode
dans un contexte un terme ministériel si
on prend l'exemple du de l'iode
effectivement nous détenons les stocks
stratégiques diodes mais on s'inscrit
dans le cas du plan iode qui est
interministériel qui est piloté par le
la gdsm et comme vous le savez il y a
également des des éléments qui sont
justement présents au niveau des zones
de défense immobilisables par les
préfets et donc on est évidemment dans
un écosystème qui est organisé qui est
planifié qui est formalisée et qui
d'ailleurs est testé comme ça a été
récemment et on contribue auprès de
l'ensemble des autres acteurs à
l'exercice de gestion de crise
d'ailleurs pour pouvoir être prêt si
malheureusement il était nécessaire
en tout cas c'est l'organisation telle
qu'elle est
telle qu'elle est telle qu'elle est
organisée et donc ça fait partie des
missions de santé publique France mais
des autres acteurs concernés on n'est
jamais seul dans la gestion de crise
pour pouvoir être réactif selon les
différents risques évidemment qui sont
qui sont qui sont abordés sur la
question des masques périmés alors je
crois que c'est un sujet qui a été
longuement débattu un sms 2020
encore une fois donc je crois que la
Cour l'a dit santé publique France agit
sur instruction des ministères de la
Santé même si évidemment on éclaire sur
les stocks dont on dispose et ces fameux
masques périmés les 600 millions c'était
des masques qui avaient été qui étaient
sans date de péremption qui ne
respectait donc plus les normes en
vigueur à l'époque et nous avions
conduit à la demande du ministère des
tests en laboratoire qui ont prouvé qui
n'étaient pas forcément conformes aux
référentiel simplement à la faveur de la
dans le contexte de la crise face à une
pénurie de masque extrêmement importante
il nous a été demandé donc d'étudier la
possibilité de retester par des
laboratoires ce qui a été fait la
commande l'efficacité de certains de ces
masques de certains lots pour pouvoir le
cas échéant les distribuer non pas au
personnel soignants parce qu'on sait que
on ne pouvait pas se permettre de les
distribuer mais à des publics moins
exposés dans l'attente notamment de la
production de masques tissus de
lancement de d'autres choses ce que nous
avons fait en lien avec la NSM
évidemment elle a demandé du ministère
voilà donc on a à chaque fois respecté
si vous voulez les normes les normes
d'efficacité des protection de ces
équipements qui sont standardisés et qui
sont qui sont qui sont les nôtres
et enfin sur les madame sur les stocks
stratégiques et les 218 millions de
d'AstraZeneca alors là aussi les les
santé publique France qui passe des
commandes de qui acquièrent et qui
passent les commandes évidemment de
produits du stock état néanmoins vous le
savez nous ajoutions là aussi sur sur
instruction et sous le pilotage de nos
autorités de tutelle évidemment de
manière toujours très concertée en
collaboration
et donc des décisions étaient prises
face à la certitude aussi de la crise et
de ses évolutions de pouvoir acquérir
des médicaments ou des vaccins dans des
proportions suffisantes pour pouvoir
faire face aussi à des évolutions de
l'épidémie qui vous en conviendrez
étaient très difficiles à anticiper et
donc il a toujours été décidé qui nous
fallait disposer d'un stock minimal de
vaccins comme on fait les autres États
d'ailleurs pour pouvoir vacciner la
population en cas de nouvelles vagues
dont on a vu qu'elle pouvait arriver
extrêmement vite
merci Madame grenier souhaitez-vous
apporter des éléments de réponse
complémentaires
non non
je redonne la parole à René Paul Savary
qui vient de la solliciter mais il faut
que ce soit très bref madame le
directrice je pense que vous n'êtes pas
prête s'il y avait un
incident ou un accident pourquoi parce
que on n'a pas la possibilité de
géolocaliser les gens et donc pouvoir
faire en sorte de les prévenir et qui
viennent chercher des comprimés puisque
on n'a pas réagi par rapport à la crise
on n'a pas modifié on n'a pas de de
cellules de crise nous permettant de
croiser des données actuellement il faut
des modifications législatives et c'est
ce qu'on avait proposé à travers un
rapport pour qu'il y ait vraiment des
des
possibilités de pouvoir activer des
données particulières venant de
différents organismes à un moment donné
dans des circonstances bien donnée ça
mérite automatiquement une modification
législative et on l'a pas faite ce qui
veut dire qu'on n'est pas prêt sur le
blanc de l'information de de chaque
individu qui peut être concerné c'est là
où je dis on n'a pas tiré entièrement
expérience de ce qu'on a connu pour
l'adapter à d'autres types de crises
peut-être sur ce point ça devrait faire
des compétences directes mais évidemment
concernées puisqu'on fait partie de
l'ensemble des acteurs qui s'intéressent
et qui gèrent cette question je peux
vous dire justement c'est une voilà
c'est des travaux qui sont menés en ce
sens notamment y compris que le
ministère de l'Intérieur et qui a
effectivement cette préoccupation de
pouvoir informer en temps réel si c'est
votre question les personnes en cas de
crise et y compris sur les gestes à
accomplir si j'ai bien compris votre
intervention pour informer le citoyen si
c'est bien ça votre votre question
merci merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames les directrices et Messieurs
les conseillers mes chers collègues ce
n'est pas fini pour nous et nous avons
encore des amendements à examiner